every burger the hell is this the
tiniest cheeseburger I've ever seen like
a burger filled with chocolate I mean
nothing's wrong with that oh my got away
there's even cheese and it has like
sesame seed bun I think there are actual
sesame seeds on this I wish this was a
cereal don't honestly oh it actually
says head open there's some extractions
here but I don't like to follow
instructions
attach the plungers plunger owl so maybe
we will look at the instruction press
down firmly with the base of your palm
to release the marble yeah look at the
marble
this is probably what babies look like
before they come out if you're thirsty
don't get this drink it went in mmm
that's not bad I mean it does taste like
a dentist's office
I like the ball I like shrimp I like
chips but come on Ian Oh lots of shrimp
oh man
it's like if you missed it french fries
with shrimp but I kind of like it
they're super good cream : they look
like beautiful little cream puffs
Colin's just what I want in a snack yeah
it's a good name for a cookie it looks
like combos but like a sweet combos it
smells of yogurt yes yes cream :
okay I'm guessing it's their version of
beef jerky and you look like dreadlocks
this isn't worm right I like this it
sort of tastes like a fish burger as I
keep chewing it I like it less than us I
would eat this squid jerky he's actually
really good at this point I don't like
it at all anymore we're gonna we're
gonna take some water here Oh